did you guys ever see the Blair Witch
Project how many of you have seen that
how many of you haven't know so it's a
pretty lousy example anyways it's a
horror movie now there's kind of two
kinds of horror movies there's the
splatter type horror movie and I think
actually those expose you to disgust and
then there's the fear kind of horror
movie and that doesn't need to have any
gore at all it just makes you afraid and
the Blair Witch Project is a very good
example of that because all that happens
nothing happens nothing happens but you
think something terrible is going to
happen every second and the sense that
something terrible is going to happen
keeps climbing through the whole movie
and so what they do is put you in a
state of radical uncertainty and never
let you off okay well so basically
they're playing with your imagination
and that can work very effectively like
it's often a horror movie is often more
effective if they don't show you what's
making those horrible noises off screen
you know because no matter what they
show you the probability that it can be
as personally horrible as what are their
monsters you're dredging up out of your
imagination is very low so okay and you
know it's reasonable to be afraid of the
dark because throughout our biological
history lots of unfortunate people were
devoured by things in the dark or hurt
very badly by them etc etc and we're
also daytime creatures right so we don't
like the dark very much so what do you
do to someone if you're going to
initiate them is maybe you take them on
they're 13 and you put them in a really
dark cave and caves they're so dark man
like if you're in a cave you just can't
believe how dark it is it's it's you
can't see anything in a cave so you
don't know how big this space you're in
is and you don't know how small it is
and you don't know whether or not it's
gonna collapse or whether it's gonna
stay up and you don't know how far you
you are underground especially if the
people who took you there didn't you
know walked around in circles and didn't
let you know where you were going and
then maybe they leave and maybe we leave
for three days and so you're sitting
down there thinking well what are you
thinking exactly well you're thinking
the most horrible thoughts you could
possibly imagine
right I'm never gonna get out of here
they're never gonna find me again some
horrible snake thing that lives in the
darkness is going to come and eat me
slowly because fast would be you know
merciful and I'm and then I'm also going
to go completely out of my mind so that
even if something doesn't eat me I'm
gonna come out of here it'll be worse
than be dead anyways and so partly what
you're doing in that circumstance is
you're facing the demons of your own
imagination and if you can stand that
then you grow up and that's what an
initiation ceremony does now a lot of
what you'll find if you look at clinical
theories of psychology the same motif
applies if you want to get better you
have to find out what you're avoiding
and what you're afraid of and maybe what
you're disgusted by evil and you have to
expose yourself to that voluntarily and
you have to let that change you and so
it's not a pleasant prospect I mean it's
not dancing through a field of daisies
right with music playing and it's not
follow your bliss you know it's not the
natural unfolding of a positive process
it's not that at all it's the voluntary
confrontation with the things that make
up life's Horrors but what's interesting
about it is that there's there's an idea
there that lurks under the surface
archetype and that is there's a lot more
to you than meets the eye
but it won't be released unless it has
to and so you don't even figure out what
it is until you put yourself in peril
now part of that you might think like
imagine that you're you're an introvert
you're socially awkward you're highly
neurotic so you feel a lot of anxiety
and depression you don't like going to
parties that's because the horrible
tyrant lives at parties and always
glaring at you and judging you and
telling you how useless and insufficient
you are and so you go there you don't
even look at people because you know
that if you did look at them you just
see the face of the judgmental tyrant
which by the way you wouldn't if you
actually looked at them but you won't
because you avoid and so you're going to
go there and you're going to put
yourself in this terrible situation and
if you're lucky and you're a bit away
then you're going to incorporate all
sorts of information
from the external world that will help
you develop your social skills that make
you more sophisticated and even if that
doesn't happen you're gonna learn that
you can tolerate your own fear and you
might say well what's better to not be
afraid or to know that you can handle
being afraid and obviously to not be
afraid but give that up because that
ain't happening so the the next best
thing and the realistic thing is to know
that you're the master of your own fear
and so a lot of what we're going to talk
about in relationship to classical
theories of personality is exactly that
it's not that the world isn't terrible
it's that the world is terrible but
you're a lot stronger than you think and
the way you focus so part of that is the
strength that you gather is partly the
information that you gather when you go
somewhere that you're not good at you
know so you're establishing new skills
like you have at university but there's
another part that's interesting that's
related to the little video that I
showed you at the beginning DNA turns
out to be a very complex structure and
so if I put you in situation a then DNA
codes certain kinds of proteins that
help make up the way that your mind is
and the way it works but if I take you
and I put you in another situation
completely different genes turn on and
so what that means is that you have a
biological repository of potential use
lying dormant highest resolution level
of your molecular structure and that if
you push yourself in all sorts of
different directions and you find
different things to pursue and test
yourself against then you're going to
turn on parts of yourself that aren't
currently on and god only knows what
you'd be like if you turned yourself
completely on maybe I could use a better
metaphor
I'll tell you a little bit more about
the shamanic routines because they're
more you know if there is a initiation
archetype which I kind of just described
teaches you can do this for yourself
there you have and this is a good way to
live it meets the alternative anyone
soul which is like the definition of a
good way to live so madam you're trying
to pursue something she's got a goal
that's a good thing you got to have a
goal and you don't want to hold on to
that too tightly because you might be
wrong it's gotta be willing to let that
go and have a different goal but you
need a goal and then you know while
you're pursuing the goal you're gonna
find out that there's some obstacles in
your path obviously and maybe some of
those obstacles are of a frightening
type well maybe they're even of a
disgusting type you might say I don't
want to turn into that kind of person so
those of you who are sort of socialist
utopian left-wingers might think that
way about business people it's like I
wouldn't I would recommend that you get
over it as rapidly as possible so
anyways you might think there's no way
I'm going to act that way so you sort of
put it off limits say or maybe you're
afraid to do what you need to do next
well here's a rule don't avoid doing
things because they make you feel
negative emotion if you have to do those
things in order to pursue your goals in
fact you should do exactly the opposite
so let's say you're pursuing a goal and
you find that you're afraid about
something and so you're avoiding it the
first thing you should think is aha look
I'm afraid of something and I'm avoiding
it dragon treasure exactly there and
that's exactly right it's precisely
right if you're if you're afraid of the
thing then what that means is that
you're not developed enough to handle it
and you need to be so you should think
about that as a discovery like a
positive discovery you found out where
you have a weakness and you're now able
to address it so you know if you're an
introvert and you think it's Friday
night I could go to this party but you
know I really don't want to then you
think oh that means I should go and
that's exactly right
because
because you already know how to do the
things that you know how to do and it's
the things that you don't know how to do
that bother you and oppress you and of
course those things are going to be
difficult to learn about but you need to
learn about them because you need to get
yourself all switched on how's that
switched on because then you'll build a
tolerate the fact that life is
fundamentally suffering and so you don't
the world doesn't get safer as you
develop in fact quite the contrary you
just get more confident and that's
better anyways because it's conceivable
that you don't want safety anyways
you probably want adventure you probably
want to be compelled you probably want
to be engaged you know if you want
security you might as well be dead well
because nothing's happening then and
there's no danger left to be alive is to
be contending with the with the world
and you want to be the best at that that
you can possibly be and that's partly
what we're going to learn about as we go
through the entire course but certainly
the elements that have to do with
clinical psychology because all of them
circulate around this fundamental theme
they have to because it's the
fundamental story of mankind and we want
to know what that fundamental story is
because you're all human and you need to
know the story and then you know you can
decide how you're going to act it out
but at least you need to know the
damning story first